Matthew starts off this hour from San
Antonio hi Matthew how are you good how
are you better than I deserve man what's
up are you gonna question how about five
hundred thousand dollars I want to
invest in no-load mutual funds in a
brokerage account and I plan on doing it
pretty soon I just keep hearing a lot of
no talk about the stock market crashing
and you know dropping and you know in
the 2016 so I don't know it's good just
to hold off till next year before I
invest that kind of money this thing
what your thoughts were on that how old
are you 28 where'd you get 500k well I'm
assisting my my parents with they they
made quite a bit of money and they're
not eligible for IRAs or anything like
that so they're looking for they have a
rental rental property and I'm still
looking to diversify the portfolio with
the mutual funds okay so you're
assisting that it's not your money to
invest it's theirs right and I plan on
doing the same thing pretty soon
no saving for a house you know like a
five-year investment so your thoughts
were well we are 100% sure that in the
coming years stock market will go up and
the stock market will go down right is
it going to completely collapse well I
don't think so I've got a lot of money
invested in there I wouldn't have money
of us in there if I thought it was all
going to collapse so I don't think it's
going to collapse is it going to fall
like it did in 2008 again
well that was unprecedented I mean only
two times in history it's done that and
it's higher time the markets been open
almost a hundred years now well over a
hundred years and it's only dropped like
that two times and in 1929 obviously and
then that and then in 2008 and it
dropped in half and do you remember the
data on how quickly it recovered I was
within a year I know it bounced right
I'm just kind of look I know I'm afraid
that we're gonna lose you know lose the
money a long turn on it'll come back but
I'm just saying if you if we really
think it's gonna drop well if we wait
and then go put it in you know in the
market at the bottom you know it would
be that would be brilliant if you can
see if you can figure that out you need
to be running a billion-dollar mutual
fund right well I'm just saying like you
know in 2009 when you're whenever I was
watching the market go down down down
and we hit that valley and you start
going up up and then you were to say you
know what we'll go ahead and best now
yeah if you could have figured out where
the bottom was you should be running a
billion-dollar mutual fund right but I
can guarantee you your beer drinking
buddies don't have a clue about that but
wherever you're getting this stupid
information about the market crashing I
don't know where you're getting that
right well I mean you know ray I know
some of it has to do with your here that
that's some [ __ ] selling gold right
yeah I heard that you know and then I
just your thoughts were all you're
watching listen if you're if you're
watching a TV channel and they sell
Snuggies and walk in bathtubs don't buy
the financial products that they're
selling right that's that's the gold
channel right all right okay so I mean
that if your financial products come off
the same channel that's giving you an
indication it's probably not a good
investment and so I'm poking at you a
little bit but I'm not sure we're
there's no credible information as far
as I'm concerned that the market is
going to take another dive like it did
before is it going to go up yes it's
going to go up is it going to go down
yes it's going to go down how is the
election the cycle going to affect it it
always affects it but we never know
exactly what it's going to do to it we
can only look back later and go really I
can't believe that when that guy got
elected it went up we all thought the
stock market hated that guy and then it
went up anyway because that guy
represented something that was
predictable so and nothing is
predictable in this particular cycle so
anyway all of that to say I can tell you
what Dave Ramsey's doing I am
continually putting money into the stock
market in good growth stock mutual funds
every single month all right period
we're
of what the rumors are rumors of wars
rumors of political cycles rumors of
whatever I've been doing a long long
time and it's made me a lot of money by
just consistently continuously investing
and and I'll go ahead and step into one
other thing you mentioned as you drove
past it no load mutual funds are not
necessarily cheaper nor are they
necessarily better right there are no
we're looking for low taxes and
dividends we don't want 1099 you know
every year with the large and say in
that case I'm probably would go in
largely into index funds and have low
turnover mutual funds why not just we're
doing all right then I'm a bit but and
you know get this next course and you
know we're kind of obvious gauging it
you know this if you want to stage it
because you're nervous or they're
nervous and move some of it in that's
fine if I was sitting on a half a
million dollars of my money today and I
wasn't going to use that money for the
next ten years I would and I wanted to
use it and I wanted to invest it in the
market I would just do it all at once
because it wouldn't bother me but that's
the track record of the market is that
it goes up and it goes down and that no
one knows exactly what it's going to do
people that say that they do are liars
or they're stupid one or the two because
there's just no way to predict it's like
predicting the weather
I mean economists and weather
forecasters are the only people that can
be wrong most of the time and still keep
their jobs that's it so hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you